welcome to this talk titled the road to
akka cluster and beyond and
this sort of shows a little bit of the
agenda for this talk we're first going
to focus on the road
and sort of the history of the of the
distributed
its origins but with a lens right what i
think are important milestones and what
have influenced akka and aka cluster
and
and
so that's for the first half or first
two thirds perhaps and then the the last
part i'm gonna like show how we actually
use these ideas and use these or
yeah inventions or whatever discoveries
in practice in aca cluster and how we
can make it all
sort of fit into our model and something
that
that you guys can use in the real world
so but i'm going to start with a
question and what is a distributed
system and then and why and why would
you need one
i'd say the distributed computing is not
really something that we that we we just
can't escape in a long way this is
really the new the new normal like it it
hits us almost everywhere if we have you
have a distributed system in almost all
the probably all applications that you
develop today even if you want it or not
right
mobile devices i mean
it's actually
the distributed systems right it had all
the problems that you might see or
challenges that you might they might
that you might see like
devices go offline and when they come
back online they need to sync the state
back and so on
and like you know sql databases are
usually distributed to some just to some
extent rest
cloud services and so on they all i mean
sort of come with a whole set of
challenges right
and and and and even
not even thinking about the network i
mean i think in my view
the way i look at it i think we have a
distributed system even on a single
machine now with with multi-core i mean
either you have
nodes separated by the network where
messages like need to be sent or you
have cp i mean course
separated by the qpi link where messages
need to be sent like
totally isolated units
if you sort of accept that mental model
i think a lot of things will will fall
into place that it doesn't matter if the
cp that you're you're you're your core
sit in the same processor or actually in
different processors on different nodes
the same models apply and the same
challenges apply
not exactly the latency is sort of it's
of course a lot lower and this but but a
lot of the
the same challenges apply i think and
just accepting that will make things
easier so what is the essence of
distributed computing it's been said is
try to overcome two things
so the information travels at the speed
at the speed of light and that becomes
really really clear and like hits you
right in the face when you have the
network because latency will be so much
higher this is something that you that
you just cannot ignore
and the second thing is that oops is
that independent things will fail
independently
i mean you have you have a world where
where partial failure is the norm
and that also puts even puts things in a
completely different context
so why would we need it yeah for
elasticity when we outgrow the resources
of a single node then we need to add
more resources for availability
if if if the node where we're running or
the the sort of the machine that we're
running things on fails we need to be
able to to like
continue servicing our users somewhere
else on some other machine
and also as i said reach stateful
clients mobile devices and these things
that actually i mean brings context with
them state do updates and then comes
back online is also
really challenging
so what's the problem then
it's just so
hard it's still very very hard i think
we have evolved quite a lot in the
industry i mean
but still
these things are just really really hard
and some of the things that makes it
hard is that the network is inherently
unreliable and that messages mean
community communication can get dropped
any point in time
and that makes it really really really
really hard i mean you know that you
can't in in a distributed system you
can't tell the difference if
if if the node that you're communicating
with it's just really really slow
right now is it doing gc if it's java or
something or it's just very busy maxing
out on the cpu or that he's really dead
and will never ever come back again you
can only take like qualify guesses
what's the case
so in a way it's it's it's uh it turns
sort of
it's a little bit into an art right it's
a little black science
you were just like estimated guesses and
try to like find your way in a way
there's usually no nothing no nothing
black and white
i don't know you probably heard about
peter deutch eight fallacies i won't i
won't go through them in detail here but
it's really
uh something that i think i encourage
you to like internalize
all these things are really valid today
more than ever
so yeah it's still really really hard i
think and we do we
we just need to have a way to deal with
that so i'm going to start with with
sort of going through some theoretical
models that we that we see today and see
i mean which how they fit into this
world of distributed systems
and as a help
i'm going to use this this mold from
this from a book by by a guy called
carlos varela it's a pretty decent book
actually
i reference this in my slides um at the
end so if you want to like look up all
the papers to look up all the stuff i'm
talking about later
but it says that the mod
for distributed computing should allow
explicit reasoning it should be like
first class to reason about concurrency
distribution and mobility and
concurrency means like computation can
happen concurrently distribution means
that it can happen concurrently in
different locations
and mobility means that computations can
move to other locations
to optimize communication patterns and
so on
so who's this guy you know
alongside church yes
so he he came up with lambda calculus in
1930
and and
i'm gonna now for all the three models
i'm going to talk about i'm going i'm
going to look at it from from the from
i'll say i stole this idea from joe
hellestein uh
berkeley professor
i'll talk about it from the perspective
of state and order like
uh
order being served in the instructions
working on the state so
if you look at state i mean
with lambda calculus you work with
immutable state is managed through
functional application
it's referentially transparent
and ordering i mean the evaluation order
can be can be it usually can be
evaluated in any in any order it's using
called beta reduction even even in
parallel and if i if you look at that i
think it's a model that really supports
concurrency very very well that's
something we see out there a lot i mean
a lot of functional
uh sort of
concurrency heavy uh
computations are very easily falls into
this or these
the into the functional model because
it's a very nice model to deal with that
but it really doesn't have any model for
distribution and really no more for
mobility that's things you can add on
top i guess but doesn't have anything
like that built in
second guy
this is john from neumann he came up
with this with this phenomena machine in
like 1945
and
it's really malda sort of designed for
the for the world that he was back then
i mean a single processor working
through
through through state so
uh if you look at state it's really it's
really dependent on
mutable state and in place updates right
and ordering you have it assumed sort of
the total ordering of your instructions
that like that that's your update this
this state this array of memory in
sequence like one by one by one by one
so like it seems like you have full
control over
over of the integrity of your data
and i don't think this is a really good
model for concurrency that's proven to
be really really bad in order to make it
to to make it work we need to add like
things like threads and locks and mutual
exclusion to like try to shoehorn things
into the von neumann world again even
though things look very differently
they're in the real in the in the real
world so to speak
it also doesn't have a multi
distribution and no molar from before
mobility even though this model the
phenomenon architecture is really what
we see out there a lot with some
patchwork on top and i think there are
better fundamental better fundamental
models to to to to to look at one of
them
is is by this guy carl hewitt
so he in he came up with a with a with
the
with the concept of the actor model in
1973
and it was actually through some
research in ai that he did he came up
with the language called planner
and uh sort of introduces the ideas of
of of of actors of the actor model and
it was later refined by student google
aga that took it even even even further
and i think that
it's a great model actually for for for
for concurrency
um and for distribution and for mobility
and and
and why essentially because state it
uses like a full share nothing designs
so you have full atomicity within within
the actor but there's no way for for any
other concurrent process to actually
tamper with the state not even knowing
what the state of another actor is it
needs to it needs to communicate so
communication is also first class
it relies on asynchronous message
passing and and you have it introduced a
non-determinism in the message send but
as soon as it reaches it's it's it's
recipient then ordering is there so that
means that you can reason with things
within the actor
while still allowing non-determinism
which is a good thing because that
allows concurrency and distribution all
these things that we want in in
distributed systems so i think this is a
great mode for concurrency it's a great
model for distribution it also supports
mobility not perhaps not like it's part
of the model but since everything is
contained within the actor and there's
no
no shared state it's actually fairly
easy to move actors around something
that we do in akka
so that was
sort of
laced out through some of the foundation
and i think that
some people might disagree but i think
that i mean in with this paper night
from 1973 i think carl hewitt kicked off
the distributed systems
until then you know people really
weren't really prepared for for it and
really didn't have a way of remodeling
that that's a very different world in
any way
sorry
so
one thing that's sort of one of the most
the most important things to talk about
when you talk about distributed systems
is what it's called impossibility
theorems
or impossibility results sometimes they
are called they these are they're also
something called negative results and
they show what is
this they prove what is not possible
by by by showing what is not possible
that he anyways gives her us a glimpse
of what is possible i mean the way to
the to like the road ahead so to speak
and and uh probably the most important
one
at least
one of the most fundamental one and the
most sighted one at least is flp pager
flp paper from 1985. it it's it's it's
it's named after all its authors like
fisher lynch patterson and it
essentially states that consensus is
impossible
which sounds weird right consensus is
something we take for granted right and
we do every day and we we
we get along with with a w with our
lives right communicating and sort of
agreeing upon up up on something but
so
one way of sort of explaining the gist
of the paper is that
the flp result shows that in an
asynchronous setting where this where
only one processor might crash there is
no distributed algorithm that solves the
cons the consensus problem and what it
so what it what it what what it really
does is that it states that under under
the assumptions
of the model sort of there are cases
sort of
ways where the algorithm will never
terminate
meaning that there will never reach
consensus in bounded time
but but as the authors state at the at
the bottom of the paper
that
they they they write something like it's
actually it doesn't say that it can't
solve in practice in quotes there's a
way like pragmatic way of finding a way
around this this proof
and that's usually what what happens so
that's also in a way like showing the
way
and and giving us our some constraints
to to work with
nothing is black and white and another
very important imp impossibility theorem
is the cap theorem
and it essentially shows that
linearizability linearization
on in in the cluster is impossible
but it is also impossible within certain
constraints right this shows is that is
like generally impossible it it
introduces this like c a p c c stands
for consistency a for availability p for
partition tolerance and it states that
out of these three you can only pick two
at a given point in time
and since on a distributed system
we have p already that means that it
gives us just one option do we choose
consistency or do we choose availability
right
we can't really get both
and it was it was a conjecture by eric
brewer i think in one of his talks if i
remember correctly it was later proven
like two years later by nancy lynch and
and this guy gilbert and this is the
name of the paper by the way so is it
it's it's a great paper i encourage you
to read it so what is what since it
proves that linearizability is
impossible what is it what does that
mean
yes it was defined by hurley wing in 91
as under
linearizability sorry under linearizable
consistency all operations appear to
have executed atomically in an order
that is consistent with the global with
the global real-time ordering of
operations and that's a mouthful what
does it really mean if we try to distill
the essence less formally it means that
a reed will return
the last completed right wherever it
happened
wherever in the distributed system it
happened on any replica
right and if you and if you think of it
this is an extremely strong guarantee
this is actually again trying to
shoehorn the world into the von neumann
architecture once again right because we
are used to think like that and it's a
convenient way to think of the world but
it's very very expensive
so if you look at cap
i think it was highly influential but it
was really really narrow in scope i
think i mean peter baillius and his and
his and his group at berkeley they you
know in this hat paper it's a great
paper by the way how
stands for highly available transactions
uh they said the cap has led to
confusion and misunderstandings
regarding replica consistency
transactional isolation and high
availability and the essence is that
linearizability is very often not
required it's such a strong guarantee
and you can very often get away with
weak with weaker guarantees
like recommitted for example
and things like that
it also ignores latency and what latency
as we've already shown in the talked
about in the beginning is like is one of
the the like the properties of the
distribution that you that you just
can't can't avoid right you can't escape
still it ignores it and and and lastly
partitions even though they happen
because the network is unreliable they
are fairly rare
so why should you then sacrifice
consistency at all times
right why what why can't we have like a
more
and more lesser open up for dealing with
things we're like sort of as we go right
more more dynamically we could try as a
sort of a best effort right we try to do
when things go fine we we we have
consistency right but then we fall back
to availability with things starting to
go wrong and so and i'm just asking
questions and a lot of these questions
eric brewer asked himself in this
in this sort of paper cap 12 years later
which is a great paper to also talk
about they'll actually read
so
time time is is really fundamental
construct
right that's how we all i mean we work
as humans right i mean that's why we all
met here 10 o'clock to hear me rant
about these things
time also need to be first class in in
the programming model for distributed
computing that's how i mean we can reach
consensus that how we can make sense of
the world i really think and
once again thanks to leslie lamport we
we now have a model for that he he he
came out with this paper time clocks and
ordering of events in distributed
systems
in 1978 where he introduces the concept
of of of of the lampwork we call the
lampwork clock now
uh it's sort of a logical clock and and
it is sort of
the sort of the the big contribution
that is this is it's starting to like
show time as
as costly related events not wall clock
time because that's not interesting any
longer you can't even keep keep like
computers in sync right even perhaps
if you have a lot of sort of cache like
google you can have atomic clocks like
they do in spanner and so on but it's
not really the model for that sort of
sustainable i think
so lampwork clocks works like it's
basically just like
like a counter like when process does
work you increment the counter when the
process sends a message you include the
counter and when the message is received
then you merge your counter by by just
taking the max
it's it's very it's very easy then not
now you can like closely sort of relate
events to each other even even though
they happened concurrently on different
machines vector clocks is an extension
of this it was it was sort of discovered
by colin fitch 88 and concurrently was
discovered by some other guy that i
don't remember an ammo or anything
nobody does so that's
that's a shame for him but
but it's it's a nice it's a nice concept
it's also what what most men
nosql databases and like akka cluster
using today and it basically gives you i
mean in in
instead of that each node is third party
in the conversation
has its own
lampro clock
you have like a like a hash map you can
say with with no two lamp or clock and
this this serve is is is what you then
send
around so so this always keeps the full
history
of all of everything that have happened
right and and and on the receiver side
you again do like do merge by
calculating the max
and the interesting thing is that the
properties of this is that it is
monotonically increasing
so it's it's sort of it will always
converge eventually
it has some problems so that is that for
example system keeps all the history
around that i mean history can can grow
in in that in indefinitely and you need
a way to prune that and there are good
research people like dotted version
vectors for example that help you deal
with help to deal with that
so that's time now we have a way of
modeling time
another thing that we need to be able to
model and to understand is failure okay
failure is is a is an extremely
important thing right and as i said
there's nothing like black and white
and it it's more of a black science
really or an art form really to fully
understand it because we can never know
for sure we can just take very cool if i
guess this and the better guess is the
better
we we're off but as i said everything
has a cost as well
so so in order to to sort of reason
about these things we need i think we
need to form a model for for thinking
about these things
and uh
so
we have something called strong
completeness strong completeness means
that every crash process is eventually
suspected by every correct process this
means that basically everyone knows that
something is wrong right that's very
it's a very strong guarantee or strong
requirement weak completeness says that
every crash process is eventually
suspected by some correct process they
mean someone knows
and and for the accuracy we have strong
accuracy that means that no correct
process is suspected ever
and some correct process is never
suspected
sort of strong accuracy you can say
that's like there's no false positives
and weak curses there are some false
positives
and ideally of course we want to get
like everything like should be strong or
a strong correctness strong accuracy
then we know for sure like but but but
the thing is that everything has a price
right and and sometimes we might not be
want to be willing to pay the price of
of that so we need to find the middle
ground here or something somewhere
so there are a couple of failure
detectors that i there are lots of
papers out there about it and
and a lot of them are interesting but i
was going to talk about two here that
that i think are very interesting
the first one is it's called a cruel
failure detector what was it was came
out in 2004
and what it does is that it keeps i mean
the name is pretty it's pretty sort of
it sort of describes pretty well what it
does it really accrues sort of knowledge
so it keeps history of all the harpies
this this that statistics and it does
that by by first so keeping like
aggregating the history and then
processing it to make sense of that
later so it decouples monitoring from
inter interpretation and it has this
this this way of calculating what is
called a phi value that means that that
is the likelihood that the process is
down
again there's nothing like black and
white
we don't know for sure
but since it returns yet not yes or no
or true or false
it returns a likelihood then we have
actually more to work with it might it
might be that we want to send messages
off to to to i mean low priority
messages off to something that has lower
like or higher likelihood that is down
and and some send more important
messages off to something that is lower
likelihood to be down and so on
and and uh
yeah and the way the way sir this this
is the math by the way
it doesn't doesn't really matter but but
it it gives you a sort of sort of this
classic j curve
uh
so when when this were plotted out
another interesting uh failure detector
is the swim
failure detector and that it has sort of
it's a lot of interesting things in the
paper but i think three things that does
stand out for me is that
it was one of the first one i think that
sort of separated heartbeat from
clustered dissemination it might just it
might sound like a good idea since
you're already like gossiping or sending
like
state around why not just
make that your your heartbeat right then
you save
a bandwidth probably right but but it
actually turns out that that's that's a
pretty bad idea because you you first
you want you you want like you want to
like tweak the these differently i mean
perhaps you have a heartbeat more
frequent than you actually have have
have
state updates or so on
and also uh heartbeats can be like
extremely really small in size right
just a few
few bytes while while while the vector
clocks in all the state that it sort of
represents can we actually grow quite
big
so it's usually a good optimism
optimization to do that another thing
that they introduced was the concept of
quarantine
that means that if i suspect the process
i don't immediately like mark it as down
instead of putting it in this
quarantines it you're suspected now and
there's a timeout that says that that
you're able to like get out of the core
in time
during
but if that passes
then okay then you're like dude it's
like set as being down and unreachable
or and you can't join the cluster again
oops
so and the third thing i think is what
is one of the more interesting things
that they added and that was something
i don't know if they called it i call it
delegated heartbeat and it works the way
that if i have like alice and bob two
notes here
and and alice wanted like check for bob
she sent bus she she sends the ball by
heartbeat say like ping or you're up and
if bob
replies with an act everything is fine
but if bob doesn't reply within within a
specific timeout then then alice just
doesn't say that bob is down i mean he's
now in quarantine instead what she does
is that she she she asks a friend right
lucy or whatever
with like sends a message to lucy and
say could you go and check out bob here
and lucy if then loser then comes back
and say bob is up then i know bob is up
and just the connection between us is
temporarily down everything is fine so
you can do that by sending out like
could you check for bob's like five
different bodies and hopefully someone
will come back and say the bob is up if
no one does it then bob is definitely
down and
he's he's
he's moved off the cluster
so now i want to talk a little bit about
strong consistency
it's essentially linear linearizability
and and there are some important
consensus protocols and
i think we can skip this we're running a
little bit out of time the specification
properties so so consensus algorithms
in terms of strong consistency
i mean certainly implement c and a
in in cap so they sacrifice availability
that's important to know in favor of
strong consistency
and some of the interesting ones that
that's come up
in order in time was first view stamp
replication by barbara liskov and and i
think this was her student oh something
okay
and and it's it's it's not that well
known even though even though it's it
was the first one the sir came out at
least uh
in this family
and it's a lot simpler than paxos that
came out the the year after but the
steel packs as well leslie lampard has
really been through the default
sort of standard the paxus is extremely
hard to understand and it's also very
very hard to implement it i mean if you
look at the practical implementations of
praxis usually it turns out they
actually deviated from the original
paper just just because it doesn't
really work fully in practice as soon as
you deviate just a tiny bit then you're
left with it with an unproven sort of
specification you have to essentially
prove it yourself to be sure which most
people don't do they just try to test
things
yeah and
you never know what's going to happen
then
so
sab
stands right zookeeper atomic broadcast
the only implementation of that that i
know of is zookeeper itself
uh and another very interesting thing is
that came out like paper that came out
in like last year is raft and raft is
interesting because the idea behind
rafting was that they wanted to do some
like take the other angle instead of
you know to try and come up with
something really funky and really really
cool i mean really really smart they
said okay how can we make a protocol
that is understood like human
understandable that's actually very
approachable
probably to teach you to to to students
initially i guess
and and
it turned out to actually actually there
is it is it is a protocol that actually
works very well in practice that has a
lot of similarities with use time stamp
replication and it's really taken off
there are a lot of implementations in
raft now and
i encourage you to read the paper it's
very digestible i think
so that's strong consistency you can
talk much more about strong consistency
i mean you should read up a lot of
interesting stuff the pete the peter
bailey's group is doing for example i
say highly available transactions or a
bolt-on consistency or some of the
things that they're working on
but i'm gonna oh but i have no i don't
have that much time so i need to go now
go through it
more quickly eventu eventually
consistency
you can't talk about that without
mentioning dynamo dynamo is like a huge
huge hugely influential when it when it
comes to this it sort of sparked off
this whole trend of nosql data databases
and it and yet again it sacrifices
consistency
for high availability
right
and and it popularized a whole bunch of
things it's a very very rich paper
it's a popularized eventual consistency
as a as i said but also things like
using the technique of epidemic
gossiping consistent hashing things like
like we now almost take for granted when
we work with like with nosql databases
also things like hinted handoff read
repair i don't have time to go through
all these but i'm going to cover some of
the other ones on top here
so epidemic gossip for example i think
that's a very powerful very simple model
and we have also sort of
embraced in in in inaka
uh the
the first reference to it i think is
from the court the court paper the later
pastries another paper came out
also also sort of adopted this this idea
but it's it's it's it's essentially
it lays out all nodes in the clustering
and know in the node ring and and and
and sort of there and there's like
communication between all them so
everyone knows
everyone right
and then it just starts to like gossip
things in a fully probabilistic fashion
epidemic is really it's really it's
really good name because
this sort of resembles really how how
like how how viruses like spread in like
in in like biological sort of community
and and it it turns out that it's it's
it's it's a it's a it's it's a way to
have a cluster to converge and
and reach consensus very very quickly
and and it has a lot of other benefits
like it's completely decentralized
there's no like special notes or no
leaders or anything it doesn't have and
since it doesn't have that it doesn't
have a single point of failure and no
single point of bottleneck you can just
scale this like
like crazy
so and it's also very very very elastic
and if you add like consistent hashing
to that if you want to manage state
across this then you can like partition
it evenly and have in the consistency
and the consistent hashing algorithms
allow you to easily add nodes and remove
nodes
adding to this elasticity story
in a very very nice way it usually that
doesn't require much administration
either it just works so it's a very nice
model and the way normally that that
resource sort of reach consensus is
through vector clocks because that's the
best way for managing time and and
making sense of time
uh yeah
yet again favors availability so
i have a lot more to talk about i think
but but i i'm going to just spend the
last minutes here just talking about how
now akka
then then uh sort of uses some of these
practices and how it's actually not how
arc cluster is
is sort of supposed to be used more how
it's implemented and then you can go
look it up or you should use it
afterwards if you found that it made
sense
so
but but but first arca is a lot of
things like is it's a toolbox like for a
lot of things around run run concurrency
but the the most fundamental thing in
actors uh inaugurs actors
i think as i said in the beginning
actors is a great model for modeling
concurrency distribution and mobility
meaning the essence of the distributed
systems
and
and it gives you one model to like think
about these regardless if you want to
scale up meaning on multi-core or scale
out on multiple machines
the just having one one way of doing
things saves a lot of time i mean
like faces a lot of thought process a
lot of design but also in terms of
maintenance and
and and and and how you and how you take
the system forward i think
so actors is good on top of that we have
we have something called io that
implements a module that sort of
implements low level tcp ip
i mean udp and these these these these
type of things
on top of that we've layered akka remote
acro remote essentially ensures that
that you have that you have the the full
distribution that you can actually you
know with actors you have these
references
to to to the actual decoupling between
the actual thing that you as a client
use and the running instance
akka remote makes it possible to
actually to actually have these
have these simply implements or location
transparency you can see so you have a
way to have to have these instances
actually running anywhere so it really
it really gives you the full
distribution akka cluster adds the
mobility so now for concurrency
distribution and mobility like a full
model 40 distributed systems and and
that's what i'm going to talk talk about
i mean more in more in more in detail
then on top of a
cluster which is sort of more a little
bit more low-level fabric you can see we
have a bunch of patterns we call them
extensions
like pub sub and singleton and like
anything you might want right
so what is hacker cluster all about then
this is so this is some of the features
that you can expect to get like cluster
membership it means that nodes can come
and come and go they join the cluster
they will leave the cluster that will
all happen automatically and there's a
lot of algorithms that we implemented on
top to take take advantage of that but
also you can look into that and getting
call backs whenever those leave and join
and where they're marked down and
and and and so on it also implements
leader
it implements like something called
singleton we have cluster sharding we
have cluster routers both that are
adaptive the story can learn how
application is being used and and
allocate routies in the cluster on the
nodes available
automatically and also when those leave
or the dynamics in the clusters change
they can likely reallocate them so here
you have the mobility
that i was talking about earlier in
class of supervision it hooks into the
failed
detection to do like
sort of sort of uh
best efforts or fault tolerance across
the cluster
so how does it work yeah we as i said we
rely in aca we rely very much on the
dynamo paper here like like really
masterless fully decentralized
peer-to-peer using epidemic gossiping
and we're using vector clocks
and and and this gives us the model
that's extremely elastic i think and
it's also very scalable i mean the last
benchmark a year ago we can probably
rerun it now i mean we we we rank
clusters above two thousand four or four
hundred nose and even even even more
impressive it's actually converges
extremely quickly these type of mods we
were able to boot up 1000 nodes in four
minutes have a fully joined cluster
ready to go that includes the virtual
instances like on on google compute
engine so i thought that was pretty
impressive
so
when it comes to gossiping this is the
actual state that we that we that we
gossip around it's a little
simplification but it's basically just
taken out of our source code
so it is it is a crdt if you know what
that is
but that but that sorry but that doesn't
matter so
for the the the the first field there is
is is it's a no it's a note ring it is a
sorted set so we we we sort them all so
every single node has the same view of
what the node ring is and the ordering
of the node ring
that is the membrane then we have
something called the scene set
and that is what it takes convergence
convergence is a very important subject
i'm going to talk a little bit about
later i don't have that much time so i
need to hurry up then we have
the unreachable set
that's where the failure detector puts
puts nodes that are like
marked as unreachable that's sort of the
quarantine you can say
and then we version this whole thing
using a vector clock
so the way gossiping works is that one
node picks a random node
uh with an it actually checks if it has
an older in this in this in this state
it actually checks it's actually first
the favorite one that has an older newer
version if it does if there's no none
exist then it just picks the regular
random node then it gossips it out in
like fully request reply fashion
and then the receiving node then checks
do i have a new like newer or an older
or conflicting version of the state if
it has a conflicting then it merges
and and and merges the vector clocks as
well
if the newer then the number is kept and
then it
this term new gossip state now with
upgraded version it sends
back
and then and then the the whole process
repeats itself basically
so so i say classic convergence is
extremely important
and and that's essentially where we can
determine that things are consistent
i mean everyone is agreeing with
agreement on on on on the notes in the
note ring whose output is down and
and and so on so we can we know that we
have full convergence when all nodes
are represent that are in the membrane
are in the scene set and there are no
nodes in the unreachable set the philly
detector has marked none of the nodes
down
and and we have some optimizations to
this gossiping for example one thing is
called bias gossip that means that if we
we have an 80 bias who knows not in the
scene table if we don't have convergence
then we check who's actually not who's
likely laggers right and then we try to
gossip to them
another another optimizations is what we
call push pull gossip and that is sort
of variation of it we haven't
implemented it all all fully yet because
we haven't had any real need but
but
the it's a simple way of pushable gossip
in that we
if there is convergence then we don't
really there's no really no need to like
send this state around all the time
when the the full
gossip state then we just send around
the vector clock
and and as soon as the node detects the
vector i have i have a newer vector
clock than the old one then you know
that you then you that you don't have
convergence any longer
and it goes back to regular like
gossiping until it reaches convergence
and then it comes back to this
we have something called a leader and
this is this idea is like it's like
shamelessly stolen from from react in in
react it's called the clay the claimant
so that was a great idea i think and and
the leader it's really
that it doesn't violate the idea of
having like fully decentralized clusters
it's just a role that any any any node
can have and it doesn't perform like
really heavy duty things essentially
what the only thing it does
is is that it it it manages
the
the sort of the the convergence and and
and when it detects convergence it has a
few do few duties and that is to move
you like move like joining members to up
to move to move exiting members to
removed and also to to to auto down
members which i'm going to talk about
just in a second
so
failure detection is another interesting
thing so what we do is that we don't in
the in in in the failure detector we
don't just rely on the nodes in the in
the node ring but we actually hash it to
to randomize the order and that is
because our failure detector just picks
the next five
to start gossiping to and if we just
pick the next five in the node ring you
know then we have a less likelihood to
actually bridge network
uh bridges like racks and bigs and data
centers and so on
and we and we use this accrual failure
detector
uh yes
but but actually in practice it has
proven to not be that that that that
that useful probably because gc often
causes way longer latency sort of spikes
than temporary network drops
so so so even though in an ideal world
we want to see like a plot the curve
like this
we usually end up with something like
this especially if we run on ec2 right
where the latency is very unpredictable
this means that this small like piece
that that actually the accrual all the
statistics gathering the analysis is
doing
like it's like out weight from from this
from the from this extra timeout that we
have to add to like compensate for gc
and these things
so that's an interesting thing
uh
network partitions i i think it's it's
really important i mean to to know how
to know how to deal with that and
so affiliate detector then can mark in
an unavailable member as unreachable
and as you know when things are
unreachable
with at least like when just maximum one
in in unreachable in their reachable set
then we can't have convergence and if we
can't have convergence that means a
leader can't
perform his duties that means that he
can't mark you can't let nodes join the
cluster or leave the cluster this means
that we have some with the classic split
brain problem there's really only one
way out of that i mean either
well in two ways either members can
within this timeout come back from
unreachable like out of the quarantine
and then things are fine but if that
doesn't happen then we need to mark a
note
mark your note is down
and and and that can either be done by
the leader by auto downing downing him
like saying you're down and we continue
without you
or it's a manual process and initially
we actually had the default to be auto
down but it turned out to be
to not work that well in practice
because because i mean if it's in the
network split like 30 nodes there and 31
nodes here and shoot it down all of
these 30 nodes actually might might like
take down the wrong one because you had
really important services running in one
part of the cluster and so on so we
actually moved to manual down and
they're now researching more advanced
autodown algorithms
so
yeah can i one minute to wrap up
so arca modules for distribution that
that using this now
is is is uh as i say like cluster
singleton for example the cluster router
is building on top of this that takes
full advantage of the cluster pub sub
that builds on top of that as well
cluster client if you want to use this
look like this like from the outside we
have also consistent hashing algorithms
and things like that so we so we're like
starting to build up on this foundation
of akka cluster and beyond i don't have
much time to talk about this but the
road ahead is that we are http like it's
a it's it's a great way to build like
rest services it's also part of the
distributed story it comes in akatu for
like a streams it comes in aka two four
as well and they were also working on i
started a project
called accuracy c c rdt that patrick
nordwell then took took further now it's
called aka data replication
and that's currently evaluated so try it
out come with feedback if if it holds
and it's useful then it's going to be
merged back in akka and so same thing
akaraft that's a product by by conrad a
guy in the in the akka team as well if
that also proves to be to hold then
we're going to merge it back
or merge it into into the core of vodka
so if you're eager for more i encourage
you to take a look at the akka.i website
download it play with it and and
let us know if you find it if you find
it useful
also if you're interested in these type
of things like distribute systems and so
on and join us at the react conf we have
i mean leslie lamport is keynoting
pat helen is keynoting to my my old-time
heroes i'm really excited about that
and early bird registration ends
tomorrow and if you really want to dig
deep i've added all references to all my
everything i've talked about here and
actually much more
so you can just go ahead and read all
this if you if you're interested in this
type of stuff i really encourage you to
do that the questions i'll take
afterwards i'll be here the whole day
so thank you for listening sorry for
running over time